so of all professional sports the NHL
hockey probably has the most
conservative fan base and owners more
than 75 percent of National Hockey
League owners donate to Republicans fill
and shoots for example who's
legitimately conservative owns the LA
Kings he's a mega donor to the
Republican party so it's a little weird
well maybe it's not weird at all that
the NHL has decided to push woke
propaganda on its fans and boy is it
Gary Bettman the commissioner of the NHL
and League vice president Kim Davis now
say they want fewer white people playing
hockey
looking at the hockey landscape in five
years what does progress look like to
both of you
commissioner Bevin tonight
to me progress looks like uh that we
become more reflective of the
communities in which our teams play that
there are more black players of both
sexes players of color of both sexes and
that we are more diverse than we've been
five years from now I want hockey to be
on the lips of of boys and girls of
color just the way you know soccer and
basketball and baseball is on their lips
something that they see as accessible
so attacking white people okay I guess
it's kind of common you don't really
notice it it's totally immoral by the
way but it happens a lot and then
they're getting even more esoteric this
is an actual tweet from the league the
NHL quote trans women or women trans men
are men non-binary identity is real none
of which is true all of which is insane
but they just stated like fact so Theo
flurry is a hockey Legend in Canada and
the United States he played in the
league for a very long time most of his
life he joins us tonight Theo thanks so
much for coming on
um what what do you make of this I mean
we're race politics a big part of hockey
when you're playing
no God no
um you know I think the reason why we
all gravitated towards hockey was first
and foremost it was fun and then
secondly
um you know there was no politics
involved you know we played this sport
because we absolutely loved it
um for me personally it was an escape
from what was going on in my home life
at that time and uh you know I fell head
over heels in love with the sport and uh
you know I was really good at it
obviously and and pursued you know a
career
uh in this amazing uh game that we play
so clearly you know political forces
hijack professional sports as a way to
brainwash the young men who watch
professional sports that's of course the
entire point of it strategic but why
does nobody push back like no you're not
allowed to do this in professional
hockey it's about hockey back off why
does nobody say that
well I think it's a really
because we're so divided Tucker and uh
uh deep down hockey players are you know
guys who are compassionate and
empathetic and and uh you know it's it's
just something that we don't want to get
involved in and then and it's a and it's
an argument that that we can't win you
know and so uh
the reason why you know it doesn't
matter to us who plays the sport whether
you're transgender gay or whatever
the reason why we play the game and the
reason why the game is so amazing and so
great is it's for everybody right and
the reason why we play the game is it's
an Escape from you know what's going on
in our lives and uh you know uh
unfortunately politics has no place in
any sport whether that's football
basketball Hockey baseball politics
should never be a part of any kind of
sport whatsoever
of course not and by the way if they
were calling for affirmative action in
the NBA I would be totally opposed to
that but they never will Theo flurry
great to see you tonight thank you so
much
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight